it's november 11th and in one week a
copy of the us constitution is going up
for auction everyone expects it to draw
the usual crowd of wealthy collectors
but the crypto community has another
plan they want to crowdfund enough money
to place a winning bid and they'll do it
using a dow
there's only one week until the auction
so they need to move fast on friday the
12th they put up a website things are
messy with competing code repositories
but on saturday they find some partners
to help juicebox will help with
crowdfunding syndicate dao will help
with legal and ftx will help with
exchange the auction house agrees to
work with the dow on sunday but there's
a problem sotheby's has to follow know
your customer rules so the dow needs to
partner with an llc two members of the
dao step up to form the llc and bridge
the crypto and traditional finance
worlds it's now monday and things are
really picking up steam ten thousand
people are chatting in the discord the
media starts catching on [ __ ] mccormick
writes a blog then cnbc covers it
donations start flowing and they're out
to buy the united states constitution
tuesday leads to more big names signing
on chris dixon and other a16z folks are
now supporting the project on wednesday
they break 20 million dollars raised
starts looking like this might actually
happen thursday is auction day and
people are absolutely stoked the dow has
over 40 million dollars now it's chaos
in the discord no one knows who's
representing the dao clearly both
bidders really want this brook lampley
places the winning bid at 41 million
but no one knows who she's bidding for
sold 41 million dow backers are claiming
victory but slowly the truth leaks out
the dow lost and the winner is revealed
it's ken griffin the founder of citadel
an arch nemesis of the wall street bets
reddit a crushing defeat
the story of the constitution dao is
useful because it touches on so many
different aspects of the current web 3
landscape so let's go through the good
parts of this then talk about some of
the bad parts and finally close on the
ugly because it gets really ugly here
first up is the good well it's the
constitution what's not to like it's an
extremely meaningful historical document
and the dow only had two rules for what
they were going to do with it it had to
be displayed publicly and it had to have
a plaque next to it that mentioned the
constitution dao's website that's a
noble goal and it's a big part of what
led to the massive surge in support the
team also did a great job of making it
clear that they weren't in this for
financial gain even though they could
have easily given themselves some tokens
for free at the start of the project
they didn't which helped build trust in
the community now to be fair there's
still a world where the core
contributors wind up benefiting from the
project the team was planning on
submitting a proposal for compensation
after the auction that would have been
voted on by the dao but that certainly
seems reasonable to me and a lot of the
core team members had other web 3
projects and a high profile story like
this could draw attention to what
they're working on but again that's
totally reasonable this approach led to
a very positive community developing
around the project although i didn't
contribute to the project i was in the
discord and could see that everyone was
just having fun and excited to be a part
of a cool story no one was trying to
inflate expectations and the core team
was very clear that the dow was merely a
governance token and did not represent
real ownership in the constitution [ __ ]
mccormick put it really well in his blog
post when he said if you want to
contribute you should think about it as
purchasing a keepsake as opposed to
investing in an asset even with this
caveat i think the fact that the money
donated to the constitution dao was
going to fund the purchase of a real
physical item is important here unlike
previous crypto projects the
constitution dao is very easy to
understand even for people who are new
to crypto at this point most people
understand what an nft is they've seen
the crazy jpegs selling for millions of
dollars and heard about massive
sotheby's auctions but not everyone
agrees that these nfts have value the
constitution on the other hand has
centuries of history behind it and could
actually generate cash flow at least in
theory although this wasn't the plan
some museums do charge entrance fees so
it's not crazy to come up with some sort
of fundamental value based on
traditional financial modeling even
though the project didn't pan out as
planned it definitely served as a good
educational tool for sparking interest
in dows the idea of a decentralized
autonomous organization is still very
new to most people but the constitution
dao helped spread the idea that lots of
people could come together quickly
online to crowdfund a specific goal and
unlike traditional crowdfunding taos
have a built-in voting mechanism it's
still unclear where these dows will go
or how useful they'll be in the future
but more people are aware of how they
work and i think that's a win for the
team behind this project obviously the
hope here was to win the auction and
propel the dow into the mainstream
zeitgeist and it doesn't look like
that'll happen but it's still remarkable
that the project was able to break into
the mainstream media in just a few days
crypto broadly has been a hot topic for
years now but most of the attention
comes back to price movements every time
bitcoin hits a new all-time high there
will undoubtedly be a press cycle
covering it and that's fine if you own
bitcoin but i don't think it really
moves the needle where it's needed most
the developer community this project
represents a step forward precisely
because there wasn't an expectation of
massive overnight gain so one of the few
ways to get more involved was to
actually contribute to the project in
some way if you're a proponent of crypto
this seems like a good development the
constitution dao was basically a massive
stress test of the current web 3
infrastructure and it clearly exposed a
bunch of areas for development most of
the problems which we'll get to in a
minute do have solutions and they are
now much easier to see for interested
developers last but certainly not least
it is extremely good that no money was
stolen here crypto is still very much a
wild west and fortunes are made and lost
every day the very first dao which was
appropriately named just the dao raised
150 million dollars before quickly
getting hacked back in 2016. even though
web3 project can offer very high levels
of security in theory there's still a
ton of bad actors out there who can scam
people but that didn't happen here even
though they lost the auction supporters
will get their money back and that's a
good result all things considered the
stakes were clearly pretty high with
tens of millions of dollars flowing into
the dow but the team handled things
responsibly and kept communication
flowing but now we have to turn to the
bad side of this project and we should
probably start with the actual structure
of the dao because it's extremely
convoluted web 3 projects tend to work
best when they are off in their own
little pristine walled gardens the world
of traditional finance is extremely
messy and highly regulated but wading
through all of that was unavoidable for
this project let me walk you through how
money was actually going to flow from
individuals to the original owner of the
constitution who was selling it step one
a contributor goes to a cryptocurrency
exchange like coinbase and buys ether
with us dollars from their bank account
step two they now send that ether from
coinbase to a wallet like metamask step
3 they use metamask to send ether to the
constitution dao project which is hosted
by a crowdfunding platform called
juicebox step 4 all of the ether
donations are then collected in a
multi-sig wallet which requires
agreement from 13 different team members
in order to move that money further step
5 because sotheby's can't work directly
with the dao a delaware llc with just
two signatories has to interface with
the auction house step six the llc would
orchestrate the transfer to sotheby's in
the event that they did win the auction
that's a remarkably complex process for
something that's pretty simple at its
core we're just talking about a bunch of
people pooling their resources to buy a
single object this shouldn't be so
complicated and yet it is because web 3
is so new and best practices are still
being developed on the fly one of the
big benefits of crypto projects is
decentralization and the constitution
dao was going to allow everyone who
donated to vote on where to display the
constitution in proportion to the amount
that they paid the tokens they issued
would allow these votes to take place
without needing any single person to be
trusted to count the votes this is a
great use for crypto and it wouldn't
have any issues if there wasn't a
physical asset involved the problem is
that the further you get from the
blockchain the more centralization is
required to move things forward quickly
and at a certain point the constitution
dao wound up in a situation where you
basically had to trust that the two
people responsible for the delaware llc
would just do the right thing i think
these issues can be solved though
especially with a long enough time
horizon it's remarkable that the team
was able to do as much as they did in
just seven days and i really have no
doubt that we'll see much stronger
patterns develop in the next few years
here but we still need to talk about the
most obvious bad outcome here they lost
the dao originally thought that raising
20 million dollars would be enough since
that's how much experts thought this
copy of the constitution was worth they
wound up raising more than twice that
much but they still couldn't win and a
big reason why is because the funding
total was public given that the maximum
possible bid was known to everyone the
seller of the constitution meaning the
person who owned it and put it up for
auction could bid against the dow
directly to drive up the price if the
seller knows that the dao is willing to
pay up to 40 million dollars they will
just bid up to 39 million dollars to get
the maximum payday from the dow even if
the dow does win the auction in that
scenario the more money they raise the
more expensive the final price gets now
to be fair it doesn't look like the
seller was bidding on the constitution
themselves ken griffin is just a
multi-billionaire and was able to outbid
the dow directly but it's always a bad
idea to show your cards before you have
to and that's exactly what the
constitution dow did here even still in
the long term there could be a solution
to this problem there is a branch of
crypto called zero knowledge proofs that
could obfuscate the exact amount of
money raised by the dao while still
giving sotheby's confirmation that the
dao could fund their current bid it's
complex stuff and it's not going to be
implemented next week but it's
theoretically possible and it would make
a lot of sense for the next project of
this kind the last bad outcome from this
project has been a bit of a punchline on
twitter transaction fees because of all
the interest in web3 projects right now
the ethereum blockchain has become very
expensive to work with every time you go
to execute a transaction you'll usually
get hit with a gas fee somewhere between
twenty and a hundred dollars even though
the dow lost the auction everyone that
contributed still had to pay gas fees to
transfer their ether into the dow some
people were estimating that the total
cost of transaction fees could be as
high as 5 million dollars but it looks
like it was closer to 880k that's still
a ton of money though and it doesn't
really fit with the long-term promise of
cryptocurrency worse still everyone who
put money in is now going to be hit with
gas fees on the way out as they request
refunds the median contribution size was
only 200
so lots of people wound up paying nearly
50 in transaction fees everyone in the
crypto community is aware of this
problem though and they know that it
will hurt adoption if it's not fixed the
ethereum team is working on eth 2.0 to
lower these fees and other blockchains
like solana already offer low fees and
similar functionality so transaction
fees are unlikely to be a major problem
in the long term even if they won't be
resolved overnight but now we have to
discuss the really ugly truth about this
project the core concept here is
remarkably simple we're just talking
about a bunch of people chipping in to
buy something expensive it's not that
complicated and yet there still doesn't
seem to be an easy way to get this done
why is that part of this has to do with
trade-offs there are good reasons for
know your customer and anti-money
laundering laws and it's also important
to protect people from scams but it
seems ridiculous to me that it's still
so difficult in the year 2021. we're not
talking about curing cancer here or
building a mars colony it's really just
moving some numbers around that
represent value when i think about the
future i still envision all the classic
sci-fi elements flying cars interstellar
travel immersive virtual environments
these crypto projects are a stark
reminder that we still have a remarkably
messy financial system and dealing with
that just takes time i do think this is
important work and i think that the
constitution dow could lead to some
meaningful innovation but it's still
just a bit sad that we have to spend so
much time untangling messy systems just
to move forward i'm definitely going to
do more research on crypto and web3 so
if you'd like to follow along just drop
your email at johncoogan.com and please
check out this recommended video the
youtube algorithm thinks you'll really
like it